also ich sehe auf der einen Seite in der
Politik Markus Söder hat das heute
glaube ich auch so gesagt das einzige
was zählt sind Infektionszahlen alles
andere ist zweitrangig ist das so sagt
ich glaube nicht dass das so gem nein
wir haben alle ja z.B die Erfahrung
momentan haben wir noch keine erhöhten
stationären krankenf Z aber natürlich
kommt das dann mit einer zeitlichen
Verzögerung auch je mehr
infektionsaktivität wir haben irgendwann
erreicht es auch wieder die die
empfindlichen Bevölkerungsgruppen also
die älteren Menschen und deswegen gilt
jetzt wo wir noch mit mit guten
Möglichkeiten etwas verändern können
gilt eben die Botschaft bitte haltet
euch an die Regeln weil es ist jetzt
viel schlimmer wenn wir wieder in einer
späteren Phase dann wirklich in einen
Lockdown müssen denn das ist das was wir
in Europa derzeit sehen wir sind in in
Spanien in Frankreich wieder bei viel
drastischeren Maßnahmen und damit wir
das nicht brauchen damit die Wirtschaft
weiterhin aktiv ist damit wir bei den
Schulen bei den Kindergärten nicht
zurück müssen deswegen haben wir gesagt
an bestimmten Stellen müssen wir
strenger werden wenn bestimmte Zahlen
überschritten sind das sind diese
Inzidenzen diese 35 oder diese 50 auf
100000 gen bin ich völlig dkord was mir
nur auffällt ist das Herr Schmidt Schan
weiß ich jetzt nicht aber auch bei ihn
habe ich immer den Eindruck sie sagen
lass uns bitte weg von dieser
infektionszahlfixierung lass uns bitte
das ganze gesamt gesamtheitlicher
betrachten Henrik StrEG z.B macht das
auch und viele andere auch das wird ja
auch gemacht auch in der Politik es geht
ja zum Teil eben auch um die
Außendarstellung jetzt wird ja eine
Ampel diskutiert das halte ich für
durchaus Berlin diskutiert wie soll die
laufen wie sollte die funktionieren in
Berlin gibt's ja da spielen eben
verschiedene Werte eine Rolle eben nicht
nur die reine sommarische Zahl der
Neuinfektion oder welche was spielt da
eine Rolle z.B krankenhausbelegung z.B
der rfaktor und man kann sich überlegen
ob die Dynamik da eben mit reinspielt
also da gibt es durchaus sehr
interessante Überlegung ich ich halte
das für sehr sinnvolle weil es ganz
sichtbar ist und entsprechend auch den
Bürgern ganz schnell signalisiert wenn
wir eben in bestimmten Regionen ein
Problem haben insofern bin ich da auch
sehr sehr dafür dass diese ganzen Werte
dort dort einfließen und aber es ist
noch eine andere Sache ich höre ja nun
auch sehr viel Radio und da sehe ich
schon das Problem dass eben sehr
fokussiert wird auf diese Zahl der
täglichen Neuinfektionen und da wä es
immer gut auch zu wissen wie viel sind
denn da z.B jetzt wirklich erkrankt ja
dass man da auch als Bürger einfach auch
das Verhältnis sieht wissen sie das
aktuell für ihre stad ja wir können das
genau sagen welcher Altersgruppe die
Infektion
auftreten ja ich kann jetzt nicht
aktuell die ganzen Zahlen im einzeln
sagen weil wir haben derzeit eher eine
infektionsbetroffenheit der 20 bis
40-jährigen die die auf Parys gehen die
also im Schanzenviertel äh unterwegs
sind ähm und noch nicht in den höheren
Altersgruppen aber es beginnt auch dort
dass auch die 70-jährigen wieder
häufiger betroffen sind und deswegen
sagen wir ja ähm natürlich ist ist eine
Infektion an sich jetzt nicht immer ein
Problem aber wir wissen aus dem Frühjahr
es erreicht dann eben auch die die
älteren Menschen und dann haben wir eben
wieder mehr krankenhausfälle und eben
auch ernste Erkrankungsfälle und
deswegen gilt jetzt wirklich dass dass
die dies verändern können nämlich die
jungen Leute die unterwegs sind dass wir
denen auch sagen bitte haltet euch an
die Abstandsregelung tragt die Masken da
wo wir sie vorschreiben wir sind ja
eigentlich auch sehr zurückhalten
gewesen wir haben die Masken ja nicht W
wir gleich im Film von von i sehen wie
wie zurückhalten wir wirklich war also
wie rigide da China vorgegangen ist in
Wuhan das sind tte Bilder jaofern die
Dinge die wir jetzt wirklich machen die
sind begründet die sind auch also die
sind vertretbar es ist nicht so dass man
deswegen jetzt tot umfällt W man
Bereichen ich ich bin jetzt mit dem Zug
hergefahren natürlich ist das lästig
diese diese Maske den ganzen zugfahr zu
hab machbar ja ich find es aber auch
machbar und deswegen finde ich es auch
eine man man muss es einfach akzeptieren
das ist ein Dienst an der Allgemeinheit
dass man sich selber auch in solchen
Fällen beschränkt Berlin jetzt
maskenpflicht sogar im Büros ist das
sinnvoll ja wir sind jetzt in Hamburg
nicht dabei ich bin jetzt froh wenn wir
das im öffentlichen Nahverkehr einhalten
wenn wir in den Läden konsequent drauf
achten ich glaube dann ist viel erreicht
ich weiß es nicht welche Überlegung in
Berlin dazu führen wenn man in
bestimmten Bürosituation wo z.B viele
Menschen in einem schlecht belüfteten
Raum arbeiten müssen dann kann das ja
mal sinnvoll sein aber wir haben heute
festgestellt Belüftung ist ein wichtiger
Punkt es gibt ja richtig jetzt ein
Bundesprogramm um um Belüftungsanlagen
in Schulen hab sie aber haben sie nicht
jetzt ernsthaft heute erst festgestellt
nein das haben wir schon im April hier
diskutiert ja ich kann jetzt auch z.B
bestätigen dass in in über 99% der
Klassenräume in Hamburg eine sehr gute
Lüftung möglich ist es ist nicht so dass
wir das alles jetzt erst entdecken und
nicht lösen können trotzdem wir müssen
eben an soluch Stellen wo es wo es auch
wirkt da müssen wir strenger sein und da
wo es nicht wirkt da muss man dann auch
nicht künstlich Aktivitäten entfallen
das heißt eine künstliche Aktivität wäre
z.B maskentragen im Freien wie es in
München passiert ja ich will jetzt nicht
wirklich es kann ja auch Situationen
geben wo man in München sagt da ist es
so eng sollte man nein ich finde das
jetzt auch fals dass wir uns gegenseitig
belehren also wer falsch und W richtig
Entscheidung triff nee darum geht's mir
nicht aber es geht um die Frage
natürlich welches Bild da entsteht Frau
Hoffmann wenn wenn die Leute also ich
ich bin in Hamburg unterwegs irgendwo im
Freien und trage keine Maske wenn ich
wenn ich alleine am Hafen unterwegs bin
me dann brauch ich keine Maske zu tragen
aber wenn es enger wird und es gibt ja
solche Situationen dann kann man sagen
dann beginnt es eben problematisch zu
werden wir achten ja auch bei
Demonstrationen darauf dass es nicht zu
viele Menschen auf zu wenig Raum sind
die die demonstrieren dürfen und darum
geht's eigentlich dass wir wirklich die
Infektion R isiken in den Vordergrund
stellen und nicht pauschal sagen jetzt
müssen wir alle wieder Masken tragen
weil es würde nichts bringen wenn wenn
wir das nicht auf die richtigen Bereiche
es ehrt sie her ch dass sie kein in
Rücken fallen wollen aber aber der
Eindruck der entsteht ist doch der eines
katastrophalen flickenteppichs was
solche Sachen angeht ja also man kann
nicht alles bis ins kleinste regeln das
ist ja klar man muss schon auch ein
bisschen auf die Eigenverantwortung der
Leute setzen aber ich ich wre mich
wirklich gegen dieses negative Bild des
flickenteppichs ich finde das das
Gegenbild ist eigentlich maßgeschneidert
und das ist sozusagen das Positive
framing von Flickenteppich und ich würde
maßgeschneidert benutzen es ist richtig
unterschiedliches unterschiedlich zu
behandeln nur und und das tut ja im
Grunde das ampelkonzept und ich wundere
mich warum das heute auch in der
Pressekonferenz so wenig im Vordergrund
gestanden hat so wenig erklärt wurde und
das Ziel müsste doch eigentlich sein
dass es eine Ampel gibt die einheitlich
gilt für ganz Deutschland also dass sich
die Ministerpräsidenten tatsächlich
darauf einigen können unter bestimmten
Bedingungen die festgelegt werden wie
hier die Wissenschaftler das am besten
Wissen wird so und so reagiert gibt es
die und die Einschränkung wenn die Ampel
gelb ist gibt's die Einschränkung wenn
sie rot ist gibt's die aber dann auch
bundeseinheitlich das ist
maßgeschneidert und das wäre auch
kommunizierbar und erklärbar für die
Bevölkerung und gut zu verstehen äh
heute die Vorgabe sozusagen privatpys
oder öffentliche Partys wie auch immer
maximal 25 Personen im Privaten Bereich
ist die Empfehlung äh im öffentlichen
Raum 50 Teilnehmer wenn es einen einen
Wert von mehr als 35 pro 100.000
Einwohnern gibt und so weiter und so
weiter das heißt das wird irgendwann
alles wahnsinnig kompliziert das kann
kein Mensch mehr im Grunde ihre dre sten
also bis 35 ist grün über 35 ist gelb
und über 50 ist rot also ich könnte das
im Grunde so erklären W es sein mus
genau das das würde ich auch sagen das
ist zumutbar und und erklärbar aber dann
aber diese Regelung gilt ja jetzt auch
nicht bundeswal sondern da kann ja jedes
Bundesland auch wieder seine Ausnahmen
machen es wurden Mindeststandards
vereinbart aber letztlich hat man sich
nicht auf eine einheitliche Reg oder die
Sache mit den Adressen mit den falschen
mit den Fake Adressen wenn dann darer
zum Abendessen kommt das ist wirklich
schlecht und ja und deswegen haben wir
auch gesagt man muss richtige Angaben
machen
wiren gehab in Hamburg da gab's
Infektion in einer Bar und dann haben
wir da 600
Kontakt Adressen gehabt und die Hälfte
davon war falsch die Hälfte wenn n die
Hälfte gewesen wäre ja oder vielleicht
auch über
die ja so und das bedeutet aber dass es
für die gesundheitsändter enorm
schwierig ist dann die Kontakte
nachzuverfolgen die Infektionsketten zu
dich brechen und deswegen haben wir
jetzt alle noch mal gesagt dass diese
Listen die Gastronomen müssen auch drauf
achten dass man sich als Gast danach
fragen muss sondern die müssen da liegen
und es soll wirklich jetzt ernster
genommen werden damit wir eben auch in
solchen Fällen handeln können aber ich
will noch mal was zum Föderalismus sagen
es gibt Menschen die von außen auf
Deutschland gucken und sagen die kriegen
das einigermaßen hin wie kommt das
eigentlich ja vielleicht liegt es gerade
daran dass nicht einer entscheidet und
der sagt wo es lang geht und wenn der
sich irrt läuft alles schlecht sondern
es ist ein Stück weit sozusagen ein
einen Kurs gefunden worden der der
Unterschiedlichkeit die es in
Deutschland eben gibt auch Rechnung
trägt es ist doch nach wie vor so dass
in Mecklenburg vorpomn kaum Infektionen
sind ja und in den wallungsräumen ist
viel mehr Dynamik also verstehe ich auch
dass jemand in Mecklenburg vorpman sagt
warum soll ich denn jetzt mich so stark
einschränken wo hier diese Gefahr gar
nicht besteht und deswegen glaube ich
ist es vielleicht auch gut das verstehe
ich aber das mit den Listen verstehe ich
trotzdem nicht weil eine Liste ist am
Ende auch nur eine Liste es tut ja
keinem weh in äh Hamburg 50 € in
schlesig-holstein glaube ich 1000 € wenn
du ein falschen Namen angibst und in
SachsenAnhalt 0 € weil es dort gar keine
Listen mehr gibt erstem ist heute erste
Mal ist heute wie mit den Masken tragen
in den in Bus und Bahn gesagt worden wir
wollen und wir müssen es ernst an nehmen
und es soll jetzt überall auch für
jemand der sich falsch einträgt ein
Bußgeld geben einfach um zu
dokumentieren wollen das wir müssen es
strenger sehen natürlich ist das erstmal
nur eine Botschaft und dann fragt man
sich wie soll ich das den überhaupt
alles kontrollieren wenn ich jetzt wenn
ich
Hans wie find ich den der sich mit
Asterix angingetragen hat frag da ist es
offensichtlich und es ist durchaus auch
mal möglich wenn jemand offenkundig da
irgendwie was eintret dass man mal fragt
sagen Sie mal können wir mal ihren
Ausweis sehen heißen sie wirklich so das
soll auch passieren und insofern ist das
wirklich jetzt die gemeinsame Idee
gewesen das müssen wir ernst an nehmen
und es ist letztlich ein ein Appell an
alle Menschen in Deutschland bitte das
könnt ihr dazu beitragen und bitte tut
es auch damit wir nicht insgesamt in ein
Problem kommen ich finde ja gerade diese
Diskussion zeigt ja sozusagen dass genau
diese problemunkte erkannt wurden und
dass man dar draauf reagiert und worum
geht's man muss es ja positiv darlegen
wir müssen letztendlich diese Freiheit
die wir uns erkämpft haben die sich die
Bevölkerung erkämpft hat in den letzten
Monaten die wollen wir uns ja bewahren
und zwar mit ganz zerichteten Maßnahmen
und so eine Diskussion wäre in anderen
Ländern überhaupt gar nicht möglich
gewesen nicht wo es diese Freiheiten
eben gar nicht gibt oder man fällt
wieder auf ein viel viel schlimmeres
Niveau zurück wie in Spanien oder eben
in Frankreich und insofern finde ich das
sehr sehr gut dass wir hier
zielgerichtet in die Punkte hineingehen
wo es Probleme gibt und die Listen
gehören dazu die Familienfeiern gehören
dazu insofern
hoffe ich dass das dazu führt dass wir
eben dieses Konzept der stabilen
Kontrolle so fortführen können ohne
große massive Beschränkung also quasi
ein zweiten Lockdown trotzdem ich hab
wir haben kurz vor der Sendung uns
drüber unterhalten Herr Schmid schann si
wenn ich diese Zahl höre 19200 so Z die
jetzt einfach im Raum steht mir schon
klar dass eine Physikerin am Werk die
einfach ganz naturwissenschaftlich mal
sagt pass auf das könnte das bedeuten
schon aber vielleicht auch eine
Politikerin die manchmal sich also aus
ihrer Erfahrung sagt ich muss auch mal
ein deutliches Zeichen setzen damit weil
es ja ein Teil der Bevölkerung git die
sind ängstig die trauen sich kaum noch
aus dem Haus aber es gibt einen anderen
Teil die sind erstaunlich sorglos und
für diesen Teil derjenigen die die
Regeln nicht ernst nehmen braucht man
vielleicht auch mal eine klare Ansage
sagt leute guckt nach Frank Spanien und
bei uns könnte es sehr schnell auch so
kommen das ist glaube ich das was man
als politisches Signal damit verbinden
das ich verstehe den Ansatz und den die
Pädagogik dahinter sozusagen die Frage
ist Herr Schmid sch wie hilfreich ist
das müssen wir uns nicht eher sagen mit
mit sie sagen wir brauchen schlaue
Gedanken wir brauchen neue Konzepte und
wir müssen uns damit abfinden dass
dieses Ding nicht mehr weggeht und auch
wenn die Impfung kommt ist doch unser
Problem nicht wirklich gelöst oder was
ist ihre das ist jetzt ein bisschen zu
scharf formuliert die Impfung wird ein
ganz wichtiger Baustein sein wie ein
Baustein genau ja so wie die und das
kommt ja jetzt jede Woche jeden Monat
kommen ja neue wichtige sozusagen
Hilfsmittel die schnelltestugören auch
dazu und ein ganz wichtiger Punkt der
gar nicht erwähnt wird auch in dem
sozusagen Dokument was heute
ausgearbeitet wurde ist ja dass eine
Klausel drinne steht dass man mit einem
entsprechenden Hygienekonzept von den
Regelungen abweichen kann und das ist
ganz ganz wichtig weil das gibt eben die
Möglichkeit dass man z.B mit den
technischen Hilfsmitteln des Schnelltest
hätten wir uns jetzt hier getestet vor
der Sendung könnte man sagen der schnell
das hat die entsprechende Sensitivität
dass wann kommt der die gibt es schon
sie können Sie kaufen die müssen
natürlich weiter getestet werden
überprüft werden für welche Bereiche sie
gut einzusetzen sind dass wir
zumindestens Infektiosität für einen
kurzen Zeitraum ausschließen können und
dann ist das eben eine Alternative z.B
für so eine Veranstaltung oder wenn
Publikum wieder zugelassen werden soll
und da kann man sich viele Sachen
überlegen und glücklicherweise haben wir
eben diese Flexibilität die lässt eben
die Politik und wir können an diesen
Konzepten arbeiten oder wenn wir jetzt
auch an die elbfarmonie denken die
statsoper wenn wir dort eben mit
entsprechenden Konzepten auch wieder
mehr Zuschauer hineinlassen können ich
glaube das sind ganz wichtige Punkte an
denen wir weiter arbeiten müssen das ist
ganz wichtig und eben alle ja ja aber
das das ist wirklich interessanter Punkt
wir haben mit Karl Lauterbach letzte
Woche auch darüber gesprochen da war die
Frage eine ganz einfache die Frage war
warum entsteht immer der Eindruck wenn
es sozusagen um Verschärfung geht wenn
es darum geht härter zu werden
durchzugreifen ist Politik sofort dabei
aber wenn es darum geht zu lockern
entspannter zu werden große
Zurückhaltung kürzere Quarantänezeit z.B
ist im Moment irgendwie noch kein
Thema geht ihn das auch so ja denke ich
auch wobei wir haben jetzt eine andere
Situation als zu Beginn der Pandemie wo
es tatsächlich sehr stark um die Frage
ging Wirtschaft oder Gesundheit jetzt
mal ganz überspitzt gesagt ja und im
Moment wissen wir ja dass die
Infektionen eigentlich nicht von demem
Geschehen ausgehen das wirtschaftlich
sehr relevant ist sondern das sind eben
diese Familien feiern in erster Linie
das zusammin und wir im Moment haben wir
viel stärker den Konflikt Freiheit
Persönlichkeitsrechte gegen
Gesundheitsschutz also das hat sich das
hat sich stark
verlagert ich glaube schon dass wenn man
sich versucht ein bisschen
reinzuversetzen in die Situation von
Herrn schencher oder von von Politik
dass es schon verständlich ist dass dass
die Verantwortung das Gefühl einer
größeren vorsicht mit sich bringt Zusam
sagen ich ich trage letztlich die
Verantwortung dafür wie sich dieses
Geschehen entwickeln also lieber
vorsichtig wenn und deshalb also solange
das in einen schweren Konflikt mit der
langfristigen wirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung kommt ist da natürlich eine
abwegung nötig aber in der Situation
sind wir im Grunde im Moment bei diesen
Regelungen über die wir reden nicht
sondern da geht es nur um nur um die
persönlichen Freiheiten gegen die
abgewogen wird und da kann ich verstehen
dass dann gesagt wird dann sind wir
lieber Vorsicht er um einen Lockdown und
um noch mal diese langfristigen
wirtschaftschieden no zu aber wir haben
auch viele Lockerung wenn sie sich mal
überlegen wie wir im März gestartet sind
man durfte sich kommum also zwei
Personen aus verschiedenen Haushalten im
öffentlichen Raum war nicht erlaubt und
wir sind wir hatten eine Phase wirklich
auch sehr schnell gesagt haben so das
ist nicht mehr nötig das wird nicht mehr
gemacht und es passte ja auch zur
infektionsdynamik die Zahlen gingen
trotzdem zurück wir hatten also eine
Zeit da wurde sehr viel gelockert so und
jetzt sind wir be an einem Punkt wo wir
feststellen
die Wirtschaft greift wieder das ist gut
viele Branchen erholen sich wieder aber
die infektionszahl steigen und woran
liegt es denn und deswegen sind wir
jetzt ein bisschen vorsichtig jetzt
weitere wie wir das genannt großere
öffnungsschritte sind momentan nicht
mehr das was wir machen weil wir eher
gucken müssen wo müssen wir vielleicht
noch mal nachjustieren und aufpassen
dass uns die Dinge denn nicht doch
wieder entgleiten also es ist schon ein
Ausmaß an an Lockerung gewesen die
letzten Monate und da war Politik zum
Teil so dass einige auch gesagt haben
ich bin hier der erste der wieder sagt
das ist möglich da wurden dann mutige
Entscheidung getroffen und ich habe
immer gesagt ja eine mutige Entscheidung
die aber zum Lockdown führt da bin ich
lieber ein Tick vorsichtiger und
Umfragen zeigen ja dass nicht ein nicht
unbedeitender Teil der Bevölkerung
findet dass die Maßnahmen zu lasch sind
also es es es gibt eine über eine große
über nicht so furchtbar viele ne
aber z 15 und 20% glaube ich das finde
ich schon ziemlich viel also es gibt
eine große Zustimmung bei ja deutlich
über
50% ja und die der die sagen die
Maßnahmen sind zu locker ist praktisch
genauso fast nicht ganz aber sind ist
geht in dieselbe Richtung wieelbe
Größenordnung wie die die sagen sie sind
zu aber die her schm da muss man da mal
ganz genau hin schauen welche maßn inil
da gibt ja wirklich große Unterschiede
gerade die Diskussion die wir jetzt ja
auch leben soll ich eine Maske auf
Marienplatz anziehen oder eben nicht
also oder sollte man Herr Schmid na ja
das kommt genau auf die Situation drauf
an beschrieben hat wie viel Infektion
sind dann da aufgetreten auf dem Platz
und wenn diese Informationen vorliegen
und man sieht da treten massenhaft
Infektion auf der macht das Sinn und
wenn das nicht der Fall ist dann muss
man sich fragen ob das Sinn macht genau
mit dieser Datengrundlage und das ist
eben ganz wichtig dass Daten zur
Verfügung stehen auf der die
Entscheidung letztendlich passieren dass
es nachvollziehbar ist für die
Bevölkerung weil sonst kommen ja die
Kritiker und werfen das eben vor warum
müssen wir jetzt hier irgendwie auf den
freien Plätzen die Masken tragen wo doch
gar keine Infektion auftreten oder
sozusagen
die Inzidenz sehr sehr gering ist und
eben sehr sehr viele Menschen eine Maske
korrekt verwenden müssen um eine
Infektion zu verhindern das ist immer
quasi die abwegung ne ist das sozusagen
verhältnismäßig und die ist eben
natürlich in Krankenhäusern die Gefahr
oder in Altenheim Pflegeheim viel größer
als wahrscheinlich wenn ich mit mit dem
Hund über den marinatz noch mal noch mal
dieser Punkt irgendwie also das fällt
auf wenn es sozusagen darum geht
irgendwie härter zu werden dann ist
Politik sehr schnell mit dabei auch z.B
die Frage der Risikogebiete me wir
beschwören in jeder Sonntagsrede
beschwören wir Europa Europa wächst
entgegen der landläufigen Meinung mehr
zusammen und ist enger zusammen als wir
das manchmal so wahrhen wollen das heißt
Menschen sind unterwegs plötzlich hast
du Risikogebiet auf Risikogebiet kannst
Menschen Nachbarländer nicht mehr
besuchen wohnst an der
deutschholländischen Grenze
beispielsweise oder irgendwo kannst da
Nachbarn auf der anderen Straßenseite
nicht mehr sehen den im Rücken dagegen
sehr wohl und so weit welchen Sinn macht
das das ist doch dem Virus egal wo der
Landesgrenze verläuft natürlich ist im
Virus egal aber wir müssen natürlich
zusehen dass wir wenn dieser
Reiseverkehr stattfindet dass keine
Überlastung stattfindet und wir haben ja
gesehen was in den sommerferrien
passiert ist dass eben aus bestimmten
Bereichen mit bestimmten reisestilen
eben sehr viele aber was ist denn
passiert Herr also wir haben zweimal das
erlebt im März diesen Jahres haben wir
in Hamburg erlebt dass die ganzen
Österreich die Skiurlaube zurückkam und
wir waren führend in den
Infektionszahlen weil wir das gar nicht
geahnt haben dass genau dort im Grunde
die Inzidenz das war im März ja das war
ganz zu Anfang um um das Wort iskel
nicht zu sagen weil die die Leute in
iskel darum gebeten haben nicht mehr so
oft iskel zu sagen das ma natürlich
genau das was wir jetzt wieder
befürchten D aus aus Regionen in der die
inzidizur sind die infektionsaktivität
zurück also ins Land getragen wird das
zweite haben wir nach den Sommerferien
erlebt also wir hatten ganz ein Drittel
aller Infektionen waren
reiserückkehrinfektion und dieser
zusätzliche Schub hat uns jetzt auch in
ein Lage gebracht wo die
Infektionszahlen höher sind und jetzt
kommt wieder die herbstferienzeit und
deswegen kann ich wirklich nur sagen
bitte reist nicht in Gebiete in denen
die die Risiken höher sind sondern man
kann eben auch in Reisen in die Inzidenz
genauso ist wie in Deutschland man kann
auch in Deutschland Urlaub machen auch
das ist sehr gut möglich und deswegen
sollten wir jetzt für diese im Herbst
geht man kann sogar im Winter in
Deutschland superh machen ich will nur
sagen das ist ein wesentlicher Faktor
gewesen im März und auch im Sommer und
deswegen wollen wir jetzt im Herbst
nicht noch einmal in diese doch etwas
unstabile Situation noch mal so ein ein
zusätzlichen infektionsimpuls setzen und
das ist die Überlegung da sind wir uns
jetzt auch einig geworden dass wir
Bundes weit eine eine quarantäneregelung
wollen die die dann einhalten müssen die
jetzt einen vermeidbaren Aufenthalt in
einem Risikogebiet machen und
zurückkommen kommen jetzt zum 1 Oktober
dann wird das gemacht ne wann kommt denn
die fün Tage Quarantäne z.B die die
vorgeschlagen ist die im Raum steht wann
kommt die da gibt es jetzt also die
bundesregung hat jetzt gesagt bis zum 15
Oktober gibt es äh diese
bundestestverordnung und bis dahin soll
es soweit sein dass dann auch diese
sogenannten aussteigerkarten dann
digital digitalisiert sind ähm und jetzt
haben wir die Lage des wieder
Föderalismus in den einigen
Bundesländern sind die herbstfäen ein
bisschen früher in den anderen sind sie
später man möchte am liebsten nicht
mitten in den Ferien die Regeln ändern
des wenn du pechast bist Du genau
irgendwo in Herbstferien und dann kommt
die Regelung genau aber das ist eben die
Lage die man im echten Leben hat und
deswegen soll es jetzt möglichst bald
passieren so haben wir es formuliert die
Bundesregierung hat gesagt bis zum 15
soll die Vorkehrung dann soweit sein
dann soll der Plan da sein und dann muss
man eben Land für Land das jeweils
umstellen ich bin dafür es möglichst
früh zu machen ich habe übrigens schon
im im Sommer darüber gesprochen hab
gesagt wir sollten das jetzt machen weil
wir diesen Effekt zweimal gesehen haben
jetzt ist es soweit vereinbart und
deswegen glaube ich sind wir dann auch
für den den Rest des Jahres dann auch
ein Stück weit sicherer was diese Frage
angeht mm das Leute die dann am 1617 in
Hamburg wiederkommen z.B Enden glaube
ich die Herbstferien hier in Hamburg ja
wir sagen ja allen bitte plant das mit
ein es muss also auch damit gerechnet
werden dass man dann wenn man
zurückkommt diese Quarantäne hat äh das
Beste ist doch immer dass Leute auch das
15 wiederkommt ist alles okay wenn man
am 16 zurückkommt ist man in Karantäne
nein nein es ist immer ein Problem in
ein risikogeben sowohl am 10 wie am 15
oder am 17 geh Reg die Ansage lautet
möglichst diese Risikogebiete meiden wer
ist trotzdem jetzt plant der muss damit
rechnen dass er wenn er zurückkommt
gesagt bekommt jetzt muss ich Quarantäne
anhalten wir reden jetzt über 10 Tage
aber mit der Möglichkeit nach 5 Tagen
dann einen Test zu machen und dann wenn
er negativ ist dann die Quarantäne
aufzuheben